l'examen du profil psychologique de
maurice papon se poursuit devant la cour
d'assises de gironde et paradoxalement
c'est plus sur la période de la guerre
d'algérie que se portent les projecteurs
jusqu'à présent l'ouverture des archives
décidé par catherine trautmann permet
d'apporter des éléments de confirmation
à la thèse de la sanglante répression
policière de la manifestation des
algériens du 17 octobre 1961
dominique vers die ashwin lamerat morts
béroud s abdelkader mort mais le couvent
amar morts tous sont des français
musulmans d'algérie mort à paris en 61
motif de leur décès homicide volontaire
autrement dit meurtre autres colonnes le
nom du magistrat instructeur et surtout
la décision judiciaire qui a suivi
l'enquète nl non lieu
ainsi la justice a refermé le dossier
ce document du parquet de paris sorti
des archives fait état d'au moins 70
morts après la manifestation d'octobre
61 70 cents 300 morts hier à l'audience
maurice papon a contesté ces chiffres il
se retranche derrière le bilan officiel
trois morts à la rigueur il concède 30
décès mais c'est un règlement de comptes
interne au fln dit il pèse soutenu hier
à la barre par un ancien collaborateur
de maurice papon soirée
centre de paris sur le parvis notre dame
on puisse assassiner 40 50 60 personnes
sans que personne ne bouge d'un ton
gaullien maurice pas pour devait
rajouter s'il ne s'agissait que de moi
ça serait peu de choses mais la france
tant que j'aurai un souffle je ne
laisserai pas touché seulement
aujourd'hui des documents contredisent
les dires de maurice papon
oui